Matthew Dowd and former political writer
Ron Fournier conclude that appealing to
three C's connections community and
civil engagement is the answer for
politicians seeking to win the heart of
the American public they spoke about it
last month at the US Chamber of Commerce
in Washington DC for around 50 minutes I
appreciate y'all having me having us
almost been quite an experience this is
a great way to to get it going as you
saw up there I have been covering
politics for quite a while in like a lot
of Americans it started to get a little
bit jaded a little bit cynical a little
bit down on our institutions starting
with politics obviously even business
and religious institutions but I've come
out of this process after spending a lot
of time on the road talking to regular
Americans and their and the people
presume to lead them a lot more
optimistic that the problems that are
facing America will be will be fixed if
not by these institutions by the people
who are supposed to be served by them
because we are so much more empowered
than we were even a decade ago certain a
generation ago you can you can build
your own CD now online you can literally
go online and custom made your own nike
shoe you can take a little-known vermont
governor or make them poison on the on
the precipice of being the democratic
nominee you can you can take matters in
your own hands reform politics reform
you can even build churches in your
community now use the internet and other
institutions so with that power that the
public now has that means the leaders
have to adapt to the fact that Americans
are empowered in our changing
dramatically so we focused on in this
book which by the way we dug really got
us going down this row really pushing
this idea of change was what could we
learn if we got outside the Beltway
outside of ourselves what can we learn
from business leaders and even religious
leaders about how to fat out how to
connect with fast changing Americans how
to adapt and what could these three
entities learn from each other what
values what strategies do they share so
we focused on was first of all was how
the public is changing and as you know
they're changing in many ways including
where they live you know two out of
every five Americans change their
address last year
about the same percentage plan to change
that or to think they're going to change
the next five years in the next 15-20
years will be a majority-minority nation
people are changing how they live
starting in the mid 1990s we had a huge
trend in this country of people finding
new priorities of wanting to spend more
time with their family more time with
loved ones actually looking for jobs
that will give them more flexibility
even if it meant less advancement being
more spiritual being more involved in
their communities this is all
statistically backed up in the book and
by other other studies 911 didn't change
the public's view of themselves and the
people around them but it accelerated
what was already beginning people to
have changed how they communicate
dramatically I you know we have our
ipods and our cell phones and niche
media it's just an incredible how we
change the way we communicate with one
another and how we receive messages
leaders must adapt to that we change who
we have dramatically changing who we
turn to for advice there was a time when
the leaders of these institutions were
looked at looked at for us for guidance
one political endorsement could change a
lot of votes a 30-second ad by a
corporation could move a lot more people
a generation ago than it does now I'm a
CEOs endorsement matter even a
preacher's endorsement means a lot less
now that a generation ago but the same
time this is a more complicated time to
live we have more information that than
ever we need advice more than ever so
where are we turning we're turning to
each other there's one out of every ten
of us who are tell the other nine what
to buy where to eat and how to vote we
all influence each other in our
conversations but some of us are better
at than others and a leader needs to
find those people also what we really
latched on was the idea that people are
changing how they connect with one
another and where they connect with one
another just like a hundred years ago we
moved from the agriculture era to the
industrial era and the old ways of
connecting like barn raisings royal
relevant and we have this huge increase
in a span of just about ten years in
that really part of last century of
these fraternal organizations optimist
club Rotary Club Lions Club boys college
girls clubs in 20 ACP all these groups
were helping people a people
taking it upon themselves to find new
ways to reconnect as we move into a new
era people are using the new
technologies including the internet to
find one of the one another online and
offline so we discovered that elite
those successful leaders who are
adapting to these changes the President
Clinton and President Bush people in
business like Howard Schultz and Lloyd
Hill of applebees some of these mega
church preachers like Rick Warren are
doing a lot of things the same way they
share some some characteristics one is
they understand the power of a gut value
that you hit people here not in the head
that you that you use your policies your
product your your scripture your sermon
as a way to reflect a broader of deeper
value it's more important to people
whether that's empathy or optimism or
tolerance or a sense of belonging and
cause greater than yourself they also
are these leaders all share something of
this is the sense of giving people a
sense of belonging Howard Schultz
created a third place with Starbucks
applebees manages it to bill itself and
actually be a neighborhood dynein in
1,800 neighborhoods Rick Warren says his
congregations of 20,000 every Sunday he
says I don't have a congregation of
20,000 I have 2,000 congregations of 10
these small groups bikers for God euchre
players for God golfers for God any
entity they can give people the sense of
community is succeeding these leaders
also find and appeal to navigators well
if we call the navigators what we call
these opinion leaders the one out of 10
at math you can talk later on about
specifically how the Bush campaign
revolutionized the finding in
influencing navigators and politics all
three of these enterprises any
successful enterprises realize that
people are now because of control their
destiny their lifestyle choices predict
what their future decisions are going to
be on where you live who you hang around
with what you buy what you do for your
on your vacation is what makes scenes
you read they determine all those life
choices determine the next product
you're going to buy the next candidate
you're going to you're going to vote for
and where you're going to go to church
so you find people and you target them
by
understanding their lifestyles and you
do that but as the Bush campaign did for
first time of politics by tapping into
these huge consumer databases something
by the way that we discovered that
businesses have been doing for a long
time as you all know but even these
megachurches I've been doing it for at
least 12 years have been using firms
like Clara toss and hexagons lastly
these folks are smart enough not to be
bought into conventional wisdom they
realize that often on what is assumed to
be the case in washington or a wall
street or in a lot of the churches are
no longer relevant as people change so
quickly so we busted a lot of myths in
this book Matthews going to talk about a
few of those sure thanks Ron as the book
lays out there's a number of myths that
and I'm not going to go through each one
but some broader ones that I think are
important but I think it's really
important understand that if you're a
believer in cycles of history which I am
which every 70 or 80 years we come to a
point where there's this great crisis or
great change and then we move on 70 80
years ago it was with the Great
Depression and World War 2 78 years
before that was the Civil War 70 80
years before that was the American
Revolution if you look at those cycles
of history they basically are composed
of four generations of people very
similar generations of people in each of
those cycles but not only we we have a
turning another cycle of history turning
at this point in time over the last
couple of years but we basically have a
contar change in how the how this
country business-wise is organized we're
going from an industrial society to what
some people call an information service
society and that's caused tremendous
anxiety among people in this country
they're become untethered from what they
had counted on before the average person
this country changes jobs nine times by
the time they're 30 years old nine times
all the time they 30 years old and my
parents generation you were in the same
job for 30 years and so when you become
untethered from that from a business
perspective and then you look at what's
happened to the institutions in this
country and people's trust in those
institutions they've lost a faith a lot
of faith in their corporate institutions
because they don't feel like they in
some degrees they can count on their
pension or kind of their health care
they're changing jobs so many times
they've also lost faith in their church
institutions
everything that's happened to the
Catholic Church in this country and
other churches where they've lost some
faith and they trust it's sort of not
been what they thought it was beat
they've lost faith in sports they've
lost faith in the Boy Scouts with all
the stuff that's gone on there and then
you add to that government which people
have had begun to lose space faith in
government whether it's at this local
state or federal level but then all
sudden you have an event that basically
confirms in people's mind like Katrina
that basically says the government
really can't is not prepared to do the
things in life that I needed to do and
so all of these main institutions that
happen in a great time of change na na
in and when this country is going
through these cycles and then you put on
that the worldwide problem of terrorism
that now is on our shores it's no longer
over there is over here in Americans
mind and that creates tremendous anxiety
tremendous concern and they don't
because of what's happened where they've
moved they've gone from an urban
centered society to a less urban
centered society they've now our in
situation that where they want to build
communities they wear on says they want
to connect they want to do a lot of
things but they did not have the means
except for the technology that exists
today which ace actually is the
interesting thing about this country is
the thing that took awaiting that away
from us technology back 80 or 90 years
ago because a TV and people could became
more isolated and they became more unto
themselves technology is now bringing it
back is now being able to reconnect
people because they can connect on the
internet they can connect in their own
home they can they can go out and meet
people around the country one of the
things so that's a tremendous change in
that and so what does that do it puts an
emphasis on these gut values that people
care about people have less concerned
it's interesting when people decide
elections and many times when I decide
products it's not the issue or the price
that's a primary motivator of what
they're doing issue in price issues and
price are now coming in the aftermath of
some value connection they have with a
politician or a product and people would
say crow wonder why how did bush when
that the people didn't like the iraq war
and they were the economy wasn't going
great and all he did wasn't with them on
health care and they were upset about
social security and all this up but
they've ended
voting with them well it's because the
president at that in two thousand four
and in two thousand had a gut value
connection that they ultimately trusted
and they ultimately thought that he was
going to act in the national interest
that's a big change in how people in how
people view things it used to be you
talk about issues and you get to
people's you get to people's vote well
today if you don't understand their
lifestyle and understand where they're
living and understand the anxiety and
understand the desire for community and
the connection you're never going to be
able to have an issue debate with people
you'll never be able to have an issue
discussion unless you connect with
people at their gut Howard Schultz
understands that Lloyd Hill understands
that people don't go to applebees they
go to applebees because it's like Cheers
it's where everybody knows their name
there's a local person that gives them a
sense of belonging that's why they go
there and we built systems in the in the
Bush campaign around the country block
parties all sorts of things to give
people that sense of belonging whatever
the issue was that they cared about the
other thing that we really sort of blow
up in this book book is the idea of red
state blue state this convenient sort of
discussion well your red state your a
blue state well really this country is
organized tribally really if you think
about it sort of red tribes blue tribes
and tipping tribes and somebody in
Austin Texas which is considered a red
state is much more like somebody in ann
arbor michigan which is a blue state or
much more like somebody in madison
wisconsin than they are in somebody like
in dallas texas or houston texas or
round rock texas 20 miles away the same
is true of somebody in fresno california
and another area the country that may be
a red area of the country but one thing
i think is that has been misunderstood
is this idea that the country is super
polarized that ninety four ninety three
percent of the country is divided into
two political parties and there's only
six or seven percent of people that are
ultimately swing folks well there's that
is true to a degree and obviously we
would concentrate it out a lot of that
in the campaign that people basically
want to pick a team they want to be on
the right team and they usually pick a
team because people in their
neighborhood are picking a team they
don't pick a team because somebody is on
the right side of the death penalty or
somebody's on the right side of civil
unions or somebody's on the right side
of some other issue they pick a team
because they want to belong in the same
community and the same sense of values
that other people in there so people
that are part of this 4747 you know
polarization that we talk about are not
homogeneous they don't all agree on the
same issues since they arrived in those
places not because of issues but because
of lifestyle choices they're very
divergent and if you break those groups
down about fifty percent or fifty two
percent of people in this country fall
in some sort of mixed mutt they're not a
conservative Republican on social issues
and they believe in low taxes and they
believe in small government that's only
about twenty four twenty five percent of
people in this country and they're on a
liberal or moderate on social issues and
they believe in higher taxes or believe
in bigger government that's only about
twenty three percent of people in this
country the mass majority of people in
this country are people that fall in the
middle that do not feel both political
parties are representing them which is
one of the reasons why both political
parties image is at an all-time low
today lower than it was in 92 when Ross
Perot run lower than it was in the 70s
during Watergate lower than it wasn't in
during the 60s which I think Doug will
touch on what that means or what that
could tell us about the next few years
elections but that is another example
where be where you have majority of the
country that does not feel that both
political parties are speaking to where
they are the other thing that we touch
on Ron mentioned it is this idea that
911 completely changed America well what
911 did was change was already happening
people are already becoming Reese
entered they were already figuring out
what was the value to them they were
already figuring out spending more times
with their families they were already
figuring out they wanted to do more
volunteer service they were already
doing that before 911 911 put an
exclamation point on that so the fact
that 911 fundamentally changed the
country and it caused people to do
certain things they were already headed
that way over the last eight to ten
years which is interesting what happens
many times in these cycles of history at
the end of one of those cycles that's
what normally happens you have a group
of people especially the 911 generation
or the younger generation that begins to
feel like what society is offering them
is not important to what's in their
heart and the final thing I want to
mention about about sort of the one of
the myths is this
idea of megachurches that we have an
understanding that mega churches are
this homogeneous conservative
Republicans bible-thumping their
conservative on social issues you know
that's only well Republicans can only go
there and organize grow me and talk to
people well in reality people that
belong to mega churches about fifty
percent of people that belong to mega
churches are Democrats or independents a
huge chunk of people that belong dead at
mega churches are pro-choice a big chunk
of people believe in civil unions that
belong to mega churches and the reason
they're part of mega church is first and
foremost is not because of some
theological tenant that is getting
talked about by the pastor they belong
to a mega church because it's one of the
places that they can go and feel part of
a community especially in the exurbs
where they do not have that sense and so
there's a lot of people that belong to
mega churches in this country that don't
fit into this convenient sort of box of
okay that's that's how they are and we
can have Democrats can never talk to
them and there's no way we can organize
them I think the Democratic Party and
the Democratic candidates have missed a
huge opportunity not going into those
churches not going to talk to those
people not going into there and saying
how are these people why are they coming
together as a community what's important
to them and really figuring out how way
to connect with those people there is
the candidate that got Democratic
governor of Virginia did some of that to
great success but it's just another
example about if you think people are
organizing around issues or organizing
around theology and you're you're in a
mistake in place because what people are
organizing around is the lifestyle
choices that they've made because of a
school because of a neighborhood because
of a community because of people that
are like them not because of a political
party and not because of some issue or
some theological tenant and people now
their product choices are now reflecting
that people are buying hybrid cars
primarily not because they they like I'm
going to get 30 miles a gallon 35 miles
again they buy a hybrid car first and
foremost in their heart because they
think it's reflects some value that
their that they care about the
environment that they're concerned about
this country and that's a way to sort of
do that people are going to buy
computers people are going to buy cell
phones people are going to buy sports
clothes
all of that stuff is going to reflect
not because it's the cheapest piece of
clothes to wear but it reflects some
value or something that that they
figured out Howard Schultz figured this
out at starbucks people didn't go to
starbucks initially to go pay four
dollars for a cup of coffee they went to
starbucks because it gave them a sense
of a different place other than work in
their home where they could feel relaxed
they could feel part of something they
could hear music they could see their
friends they can get on their Wi-Fi but
it wasn't primarily driven by coffee or
the cost of coffee there so there's a
number of of Miss we talked about in the
book related to business churches in
politics and Doug cynic it up and I hope
we're going to have an interaction we'd
be happy to take as many questions as as
the leading authorities in the US
Chamber will stand so Doug you don't
mind I'm going to stand up here I
couldn't see many of you in the back I
guess for purposes of this discussion
this is a business tribe is that
Democrat he's been in this town for a
long time I don't know what the big deal
is about changing jobs and nine times by
the time you're 30
just lucky to have one I if you believe
in the cycles of history which I think
we do and we also believe we're at one
of those moments a couple of things to
keep in mind and one is when you're in
the middle of something it's hard to see
it it's hard to see if it's actually
happening because you're right middle of
it the other is when when things change
if you've been doing something for a
long time and you think you understand
what you've been doing and you think you
know what you're doing it's very
difficult for you to adapt to these
changes you know they say about the best
airline pilots not the ones who've been
doing it forever we think they know
everything and they're not the ones who
just started who don't know what they're
doing it's the ones in the middle who've
been doing it long enough to know what
they're doing but haven't been doing it
so long that they think they know
everything and so for those of us we've
been at this business whatever that is
in town here and think we know this
business we've got to change and in some
ways it's harder for us to understand it
because in the sense we're a victim of
our experiences and this change I want
to summarize very briefly when my
colleagues said it talk a little bit
about what what this means going forward
politically in our country the change
that's been going on in the last 15
years in our country if any of these
that changes that that my colleagues had
spoken about it happen in isolation it
would have been significant but what
makes this time so I think historic is
the fact that all these changes are
happening on top of each other and just
to summarize some of the things that
they talked about these five changes
roughly one the demographic shifts in
our country in terms of who we are
secondly the technology changes in our
lives how we get information and how its
impacted on how we live where we live
third in part because of the technology
the globalization has taken its taking
place in the world and how it's affected
all of our lives for better and for
worse for the institutional failures in
Matthew talked about they really go
across the board in our country from
Wall Street to the church to sports on
the Boy Scouts to politics to government
and lastly 911 which I think our view is
is that obviously was an enormously
significant event but in many ways it
was a tipping point for what people have
been feeling prior to 911 and that was
one that this really the sensible clack
loss of control in their lives desire to
get more of a balance in your life
between work and their families and also
that a sense of feeling of alienation
they've been fighting the book Bowling
Alone in which people want to be part of
something larger than just themselves
and so what we found a little bit to our
surprise is the people who were in
politics business and religion who've
been successful in navigating his period
of change they actually had more in
common with each other the differences
in terms of how they approach the
marketplace there in in this world of
change and were successful and what they
did first and foremost was a they reach
people at an emotional level rather than
an intellectual level and that was very
important in success of obviously
President Clinton and Bush but also as
some of the things that Matthew is
talking about on starbucks at applebees
but clearly in the megachurch movement
and secondly particularly in politics
and in mega church movement the
importance of making people feel part of
the community part of something larger
than themselves and talking about their
aspirations and goals in politics
towards appealing to that and thirdly
the realization that we're back to where
we may have been 75 80 years ago and how
important grassroots bottom-up neighbor
to neighbor communication is and how
influential people in our communities
through people in politics have sort of
forgotten about but being able to
connect to people through these
navigators we call them these leaders is
essential element of success certainly
in the bush campaign certainly in the
megachurch movement and also in a number
of businesses now as you see how they
are redeploying their resources away
from the networked national television
buys and much more of a bottom-up
approach through these use of navigators
and fourthly what they have been able to
do is not only understand these changes
in technology but also be able to
communicate to people through these new
technologies and I think first and
foremost the Bush campaign was really
really smart in how they did that was to
understand a person's lifestyle is to
understand a person and so that's the
reason why when the kerry campaign were
putting up national media buys 25
million dollars more than the Bush
campaign
they took 25 million off of that
national television buys and brought you
know closed-circuit television and gems
so the people that they had identified
working out fit their targeted audience
and there were much more strategic in
their communications and so the the
strategy and tactics are merging between
politics business and religion and I
think people in business would probably
laugh at Helen sophisticated people in
politics again in terms of taking
advantage of all this data and life
targeting that Matthew talked about the
Bush campaign did in 2004 and so people
in politics now beginning to do things
that people in business have been
assuming this is how you do everything
for the last quarter of a century in the
ocean I mean to think about how much
American Express knows about you just by
pulling up your file and then able to
analyze all your purchases when you
purchase how much they have an enormous
amount of data that people in politics
are now only for the first time
beginning to understand the people in a
and business are also understanding that
as this world changes that they can't be
like a battleship that takes five or ten
years to turn and they have to be much
more sensitive in real time to reacting
to what's going on much like a political
campaign take walmart as an example
which is no matter what your politics is
it's gently relays favorite example but
if you take walmart there they're an
example of what happens in this new
world that we're talking about here when
you don't care about the community and
don't focus on the community and leave
it alone and they paid a price for that
but they've also i think begun to
understand how important that is and
you're seeing that be much more involved
now in the local communities their
advertising skeered more to the local
communities there now investing in the
local communities they've paid a big
price by waiting but they've also
figured it out have made adjustments
they are also operating now as if
they're in a political campaign as it
relates to their public image and they
have a war room and all the
accouterments that you see in a
traditional campaign probably the people
that have taken all of this and done
what you might call best practices has
been the mega church movement these are
the people that are taking the best
practices of how you run a successful
political campaign in this world that
we've described to change but also with
the sophistication of a business world
so how you take data information and
communicate with people and what we
found in was that really regardless of
whether you're selling hamburgers trying
to get some of the join your church or
where they try to get some the vote for
you now the elements to be successful
are really quite similar across all
those areas and that's what our book is
about if you if you if you look at where
we are right now and change I have
people in Washington or breathless with
every up and down in the polls in the
midterm elections and if the Democrats
take the house back it's going to be all
business there I mean it's all important
don't misunderstand me but but we are at
the edge of an enormous change in our
country and the 2008 presidential
campaign is going to be the beginning of
that new era and the debate that we're
going to have in 2007 in 2008 we're
going to determine what the president
whoever that is does in January of 2009
campaigns matter like Bush don't like
bush we basically ran on a bunch of
things he said he would do you got
elected he's been doing it and and so we
are moving into a period in which in
this 2007 2000-2008 period that debate
is going to determine our policies much
more so than what happens on the hill
next year and the year after and and so
when you think about who's the right
kind of person to be the next president
I think we all agree that country wants
change but I think that's a kind of a
broad term what does that mean and what
kind of elements do you want in your
next leader that's something I think
it's much more difficult to know but i
think this the thing that that we were
really struck by and part matthew
alluded to it is the consumer is now in
charge they can decide what they want
how they want it when they want it and
where they're going to get it if you
don't give it to me over there somewhere
else I think this General Motors proved
in the 70s and 80s that they'll build
the car they want the consumer will buy
it is probably not the best strategy
going forward but you can go on a
website now and pick out your own car
you can go on like E and design your own
tennis shoe but you've got to understand
that the the relationship between the
buyer and the seller is now completely
on its side and the buyer is in charge
and so I believe the person who'll be
successful in the next
campaign first and foremost has to be
authentic I think we can say that the
that the country in politics is in a in
a spine post spin era and it's far less
important that they agree with you on
everything then they come away bleep
thinking that you actually have a core
and believe in something and I think
this country really is looking to be
brought together as opposed to
continuing to be divided we've been in a
debate and it takes two sides to have a
debate we've been in the same debate in
this town in this country at least in
this town politically really since
january of 1993 or bill clinton took
office and i think the country is really
tired of discussion and they would like
a new discussion they might even like
some new people discussing new things
but there are a lot of people that are
in play for either party to get and
they're most people don't think of
themselves as blue or red and Democrats
or Republicans and most people don't
choose to go to lunch in the middle of
the week and talk about politics and we
just kind of live in their life but the
candidate who's authentic appeals to
people here talks about bringing this
country together with a vision appeals
to people's desire to be part of
something larger than just themselves
and tactically understands that to be
most effective politically in getting
ahead is a bottom-up neighbor to
neighbor cotton working through these
navigators these local community leaders
they're going to be the ones that will
be far more successful and harnessing
this technology to be able to reach
people and give them information and and
the people that understand this change
and don't run the last campaign but
understand all these things that how
it's changed our country help what
people are feeling looking for in the
future the person who's able to do that
is the one who's going to win but hey if
if the political parties continue to
stay where they are in terms of this
debate and don't change what they're
saying and actually more importantly
what they're doing it's going to create
an enormous opportunity for a third
party to come in and fill that void
there's people are scared and they're
looking for solutions they want to be
part of the solution they want some what
they want to be given a vision of
whether how the country is going to go
and I think the political debate has
winded down now after 14 years in which
they're not getting that from anybody in
2007-2008 the debate the next campaign
is going to determine what happens
policy was in January of 2009 so I think
thank you all very much and I think
we'll take your questions how do you go
ahead and pick them how about right over
here hi bobby nichols American
Veterinary Medical Association he
mentioned the potential emergence of a
third party it does seem like neither
political party really represents a
majority of people what would happen
what would have to happen for the
emergence of a significant third party
we probably each have similar maybe
dissimilar answers I think Doug's right
it's the numbers that I alluded to which
is the views of both political parties
are as bad as they've ever been that's
one one thing that has to happen so
that's exists the next thing that I
think that is probably going to happen
that will that will push towards that is
the 2006 elections in November because
in the aftermath of those regardless of
what your prediction it will be it will
be a closer margin in the house either
by Democrats in charge or Republicans in
charge and a closer margin in the Senate
probably Republicans in charge but
basically by either house center of the
house will be two or three votes with a
president that has a job approval rating
in the low 40s that's what november
eighth will look like and the american
country is going to look at that and say
this we're going to be it's going to be
worse than it's been because nothing's
going to get done there's going to be
screaming and yelling there's going to
be all that so that's another thing i
think that's going to push towards that
but ultimately i think the answer to
that question lies and who the parties
nominate if the parties each of both
political parties nominates very
polarizing people that only appeal to
that 23% that is part of the democratic
party in that twenty-five percent that's
part of the Republican Party that is
what will allow a huge window of
opportunity for somebody to fill that
void now if one of the political parties
it's somebody that's authentic that try
says they're going to bring the country
together that has new ideas a new vision
that wants to get past that it's going
to be very difficult for a third party
to to find a window in that but if the
political parties nominate polarizing
people that only appeal to those
segments then I think it's it's it's
fertile ground for a third party to come
into play one more thing that has to
happen that is happening is is the
lessening neediness is something Doug
should speak to the less they need for
money in the political system and how
somebody can come from outside the
current process because of technologies
I think it's fashionable to talk about
all awful politics is and it's all
controlled by money and that awful and
all that the fact is if you wanna run
for president you do need to raise 10 15
million dollars to be able to that's the
kind of the point of entry and basically
if you can't organize a political
campaign to raise 10 or 15 million
dollars even though business thinking
you can run this country but but beyond
that the Pew survey after the elections
show that a third of the people who gave
to John Kerry never were asked I just
gave with the internet now people are
people looking regardless of their
political persuasions people are looking
forward now looking for leadership and
they want to see someone who's able to
deal with these problems in our country
and do something about it and the
candidate who is able to get out there
and to be able to express that the money
will follow having enough money to run a
presidential campaign is not going to be
an issue if the person running has a
vision for the future and is able to
articulate that to the American public
here
the chamber you all mentioned that
navigators do you give a description of
them and how is it sees Navigator is
flying very direct sure the navigators
it's a broad group of people as Ron
mentioned it's prob about ten to fifteen
percent of people in this country that
are huge consumers of information that
decide the credibility and Trust of a
product a candidate a church of school
they are the sunday-school teacher or
they are the person that coaches Little
League it's the person if you can think
in your neighborhood or in your
apartment complex if you can thank who t
is it you usually go to and say hey it's
a good steak place or did you see that
movie and the more times than or not
they gave you a good recommendation and
what they said was true it's just
average people that sort of get gather
information and you trust them on
whatever level rd I saw those television
commercials on bush do you think that's
right or you think that's wrong or what
do you think about that now these are
people that write letters to the editor
that do call in they get there are that
goat that are asked for product
recommendations and I think part of the
success in business which you already
see in this whole idea of buzz marketing
and all that sort of thing it's their
attempt its people's attempt we did a
lot of this in the bush campaign is
trying to figure out how to find those
people and then talk to them and these
people while huge consumers of
information have their radar up big time
they can't be marketed to you can't
market them to a position you can't say
I'm going to send this slick brochure or
send this slick video and think you're
going to get a navigator or somebody or
an influential or whatever the term of
art you want to use for them and get
them to a position they have to trust
the information it has to be real it has
to be authentic and most of the time it
has to be delivered in a personal way
not through a television commercial but
through somebody else that they might
know or through a way that somebody
forwards it to him on the internet and
to me the interesting thing that
happened is that what everybody said was
going to happen which was technology and
cable and and every average person
heaven 90 do channels and people's
ability to go get their own information
was caused people to be less dependent
on others they'd become self-reliant
they become independent they could log
on the internet
their stuff they could decide well in
reality what happened is because so much
information and the loss of faith in the
institution is cut through the reverse
happened they've become more dependent
on these navigators or influentials to
give them that information to give them
a level of trust and so the reverse
happened with technology technology
didn't make people more self-reliant
technology became more people and more
reliant on other people you talk to how
you use technology to find the
navigators among your seven million
volunteers well one of the things that
we've figured out in the course of the
campaign was there certain questions
that you could ask people to get a
pretty good idea that they were
navigator there's five or six questions
that you can ask that you've probably
with 85 or 90 percent likelihood which
we don't say in the book which those
questions are it's one of the things we
don't say but I'm happy to have a
conversation with you afterwards or
whenever about that and then what we did
was we figured out what kind of
communications that we tested it how
often do they like emails was to emails
a week too much was one email too much
how much information was something that
was a hundred words long what did what
kind of pictures all of that kind of
stuff was they could tell you and the
ultimate conclusion of it as I said was
they don't want to be marketed to they
don't want spin as doug said they want
sort of real information in a way and if
you could figure out somebody to knock
on a navigators door go into community
and talk to them in person you're going
too much more success with them and I
think this is where the business world
is headed they're going to put much more
money in the business world in in in
trying to figure out who these people
are in a community and trying to get to
talk to them then they are going to be
in a super bowl add the procter gamble
is already taken a lot of their money
off of your network lies and put it into
a subsidiary they have called tremors
that gets products in the hands of
youngsters who navigate to their their
colleagues well gap gap the gap store
hires kids on college campuses the
populace keep popular kids on college
campuses in high schools to wear their
clothes to the people that are going to
become Tuco do they're going to give a
signal they do that already so their
business is starting to figure this out
that the importance of this
questions over here
virgina harsanyi with tyco international
I think I understand your description of
navigators and all these millions of
community cells around the country I
think you have really stood political
science or what political scientists
have taught for a long time on his head
because political science has the
concept of integrators as opposed to
navigators at some point how do how do
all these people come together who who
does that what kind of organization does
that used to be the political parties
that then drive it to decision which is
essential to govern so how does that how
does that process take place well yeah
it's a great question I think what's
happening and correct me if I'm wrong is
those institutions are being overrun
that people are taking over they're
turning to each other for information
and they're they're building communities
amongst each other they're of taking
charge of politics they're deciding
exactly what music they want to have on
their cds and if the folks who presume
to lead us don't bow to our will like
like doug said we now have the ability
to get it done the way we want to do it
or take it over or fix it ourselves oh
and I'll add one thing to that I think
all that's true and I think people are
organizing a month themselves but they
still feel like the government in large
institutions are supposed to play a
fundamental role in society and that's
what they're really mad about because
they feel like we have a system that was
designed they look at our system of
government take a look at the system of
government in Washington and how its
organized we have a Labor Department
that basically is organized for a
industry in this country that hasn't
been in place for 50 years the Labor
Department the Commerce Department still
acts as if we need to have people that
can go over to a foreign country and
introduce you like there's no like we
don't can't get on an airplane like we
can't send an email the State Department
and organized in such a way like there's
no CNN or fox or whatever that we need
some ambassador
call back up and say here's what's going
on in Libya we have in the government
that almost every single level is
organizing in a way that doesn't meet
the needs and the desires in the
concerns of people today and we wonder
why in the aftermath of 911 and
everything that happened and we try to
throw all these departments together to
deal with terrorism and all that kind of
stuff we still have basically we built a
bureaucracy to deal with akin tirely
different issue and we to a large degree
built it in many of the same ways that
we've built other bureaucracies and so I
think to speak to Doug's point not only
you're going to have some of that's
gonna have to be authentic that's piqued
gives people broader interest I think
you're going to have to have somebody
that basically stands up and says we do
need large institutions in this country
the government is an important
institution in that how are we going to
make it work for four people in the 21st
century that they actually will feel and
trust that it can be responsive to
somebody's going to have to figure out a
way to do that in a way to bring that
we've reorganized corporations in this
country we've done a lot of different
things we stood the government seems to
be the last vestige of something that
you're going to drag you know screaming
into the 21st century and somebody that
speaks to that and it doesn't have to be
a Republican that says streamlined
government and all that it's going to it
could be a Democrat that stands up and
say here's how to make government work
and one of the ways to make government
work is to localize things or to do
something that you youyou whatever those
the best theories and practices are but
i still believe while it's organized in
a community in a local level with the
American public sits here and thinks we
got to have large institutions in a way
that that deal with things and right now
it's not and we have in the book a
section at the end about the 911
generation and it's a look around the
room I don't think there's a member of
the 911 generation here but over the
long haul our country it's going to be
quite different when the 911 generation
takes over our country in terms of being
40 50 years old and charger businesses
and companies and corporations and we we
think they're much more like their
grandparents the greatest generation
then the baby boomers in terms of how
they approach life they may they may
express it differently than their
grandparents but they're much more civic
oriented than
boomers are the more spiritual they
don't have to reprogram themselves about
all this change because they were bought
up you know with this changes the new
the new new and so they are completely
organizing themselves differently than
what we use through there are not many
911 generation people that are racing
home at six thirty at night to watch the
evening news or by the newspaper and if
you look at how they're organizing over
the Internet you are seeing that as they
get older more influential in our
society they are going to create the new
new we can't completely get rid of the
old old but the old old is massive
renovation you see in corporate America
right now the companies that don't
change die and it's also true in
politics if you look at how people run
the same kind of campaigns as if it's
1994 1996 they're the ones who lost in
2004 what we know about this generation
coming up is there more tolerant they're
more diverse young ladies are running
generation women are going to be running
things when they come of age and they
are they've grown up in an era of
technology they expect results they
expect when they hit a button they're
going to be I'll have a library at their
fingertips they expect when they hit
itunes or you have exactly two music
they want they're not going to put up
with this BS they're not going to be as
easily spun as our parents were even
even our generation they're not going to
be put on hold right as I mean they are
not going to be put on hold if they get
put on hold by a restaurant they're
going to hang up the phone or go to the
thing and go to another one they're not
gonna be like oh I got to do this and
not going to be put on hold a politician
tries a fee to malign abuse are going to
get it move on to the next one we have
one time for one last question over here
Rick stam burger with smartbrief each
time you mentioned authentic authentic
people i'm reminded of George Burns is
comment that honesty and sincerity of
the two most important things once you
can fake those you can get anything so
I'm wondering looking forward because
you look back at the last election
looking forward if you were advising a
presidential candidate on each side what
would give a taste of one of the
tactics since after they read your book
they're going to be wandering into every
mega church and they'll be stopping by
every applebees what give a taste of
something new to the cat it has to do
too I joked residential Canada a couple
weeks ago that I would make a mistake
every week and take accountability for
it and I'd make a mistake and say oh I'm
sorry here's I'm going to fix it people
are that hungry for authenticity that I
agree with that and one of the things
that I think candidates can't do is the
sole try this whole thing triangulation
I'm going to do this to appeal to this
group and they'll that will work over
here then I'm going to do this I'm gonna
go give a speech to this group I think
Ron is right if I and you have to also
have to take accountability immediately
you can't take accountability in the
aftermath of five editorials and two
news stories and and then I'll said and
say oh I'm sorry for what I did five
days ago you got to make a mistake you
got to take a kind of Billy for it and
basically say I'm a human being like
your human being I think American public
doesn't want consistency this idea that
somebody has to have the same position
when the 20 years ago as they had that
heaven and enter 10 years ago as they
had to have when they're five years ago
and the politicians make all these
contortions to try to argue well in
reality I am consistent and here's why
when the best thing they can do and said
you're right I believe that 20 years ago
society changed I changed here's the
reality this is how I think we ought to
approach it and that so it is now if you
don't think if you think consistency is
you think I have to have the same
position you know 20 years ago that I
have today then you don't shouldn't vote
for me but if you think the world's
change and I've changed and you've
changed then you ought to understand
that that's what I think politicians but
you watch them on the news you watch
them all the time somebody says what you
said this and use and now you say this
they should just say you're right I did
and I changed and the world changed and
that's why instead of like well not
really I really said this and I meant
this and I had to say this and and this
then that's inauthentic I don't know the
other good value it does spoke to was
was community the sense of will make you
a part of a Cause bigger than yourselves
people are very hungry to do something
greater than what you might think are
their self-interest or selfish interests
they want to make their country better
their neighborhood better
other community better I would just say
they're the three biggest mistakes that
politicians make occur when either one
they're tired to their drop their guard
in terms of not being focused and three
is when they're not themselves and we
can think of a few candidates who've run
for office in the last few years who may
have appeared to the voters to
continuing reinvent themselves and
that's bad for business and we've proven
that heavenly and and the worst thing
that guys like me and Matt can do and
advising a candidate is to get them in a
place to be somebody who they're not
because the voters can smell it and the
price that you pay now in politics
because of the change we've been talking
about you pay much higher price now of
committing that error and so you've
really got to make it real it sounds so
basic and I think the first time I've
heard George Burns his name in 15 years
but it goes back to when George Burns
was around I don't think much has
changed about that except that that the
desire and hunger for that authenticity
is much greater now than it's ever been
before in our country well I'd like to
thank Matthew run and Doug for a great
insight into their new book and they're
gonna be around for a while you have
complimentary copies of the book so if
you'd like to have it signed to come up
but you know you might want to think
about Hanukkah and Christmas getting
books for your friends borders and Deb
but thanks once again to them and thanks
to the chamber